[Applaus]
man soll Feste feiern wie sie fallen
auch wenn es schwer fällt auch wenn sich
ein gigantisches Loch aufgetan hat
ausgerechnet in der größten Haushalts
und
ampelregierungskrise feiert die
Kreditanstalt für Wiederaufbau die
Investitionsbank von Bund und Ländern
ihr 75
Jubiläum lassen Sie mich gleich zu
Beginn meiner kurzen Rede einige
elephants in the aus dem Weg räumen zum
ein ich heute Abend nicht über die
aktuelle Lage in Berlin sprechen ich
werde auch nicht über den Bundeshaushalt
sprechen und auch nicht über die
möglichen Auswirkung für die KfW
Ehrengast ist Kanzler Olaf Scholz der
auch weiß worüber er nicht sprechen will
der Applaus für Scholz Verhalten
schließlich liegen jetzt milliardens
schwere Förderprogramme auf Eis Scholz
kommt mit leeren Händen und leeren
Worten
natürlich wird das mit Investitionen
jetzt auch noch noch mal neu zu
organisieren sein ich und andere haben
es schon wiederholt gesagt wir wollen
uns dieser Aufgabe stellen und werden
das auch hinbekommen je länger Scholz
nichts Konkretes sagt desto schlimmer
raunt es hier im Publikum mindestens
zwei schuhnummern zu groß sei das Amt
für Olaf Scholz wütet Friedrich märz im
Bundestag wenn sie weiter unsere
Staatsfinanzen gefährden und unsere
Volkswirtschaft vor die Wand fahren dann
werden wir alles dafür tun dass der Spuk
mit ihrer Bundesregierung so schnell wie
möglich beendet wird als Reaktion die
Flucht ins Handy die Regierung auf der
Anklagebank Scholz ein Tricker die
Opposition geht hart mit ihm ins Gericht
die beliebtheitsaktie des Kanzlers im
freien Fall seine Regierungsarbeit so
schlecht bewertet wie noch nie ich
glaube die Menschen erkennen zur Zeit
mit Sicherheit auch ein
führungsdefizit aber Führung an solche
ist ja erstmal wertfrei und es hängt
natürlich lich auch davon ab welche
Inhalte eine Führung dann präsentiert
und an beidem mangelt es momentan in der
aktuellen Situation ganz offensichtlich
die SPD Basis im Hamburger Westen mach
sich bei ihrer
jahresausklangfeier gemütlich bei
ungemütlicher Lage den Olaf den kennen
Sie hier und hätten ihn doch jetzt gerne
anders man wünscht sich manchmal dass er
also wirklich auch Politik lauthals
verkündet
äh man muss sie schon dazu zwingen
gerade ein angetragt dessen dass wir so
eine schwierige Situation haben dass wir
da drüber mal nachdenken wie eigentlich
z.B die Subventionen ob die alle
wirklich so klimawichtig sind
Handlungsreisender in Sachen
Schuldenbremse gab Bundesfinanzminister
Lindner vor zu sein sein Amt hat er
darauf aufgebaut beide Erzählungen vom
eisernen Christian und dem
kühlrechnenden sorgfältigen Kanzler sind
jetzt erst einmal auserzählt ohne eine
neue Erzählung zu haben
selbstverständlich muss ich in
schwierigen Zeiten mich besonders
intensiv um die Kommunikation kümmern
und den Menschen die Problematik
erklären und eine Perspektive aufzeigen
wie ich aus der Misere herauskommen will
es ist dieser alte oft zitierte
scholzsatz wer bei mir Führung bestellt
muss wissen dass er die dann auch
bekommt doch gerade jetzt fehle Plan und
eben Führung
wir brauchen eine Zeitansage der
regierenden die Vertrauen wachsen lässt
und nicht vertrauen minimiert wir
brauchen eine neue Bereitschaft mit der
Bevölkerung so zu sprechen als wäre die
Bevölkerung erwachsen es ist die Suche
nach Antworten in der wohl größten Krise
seiner Kanzlerschaft die Wucht die das
Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichts
entfaltet zeigt seine Führungsschwäche
und wirft die zentrale Frage auf was die
Ampel in ihrem Innersten
zusammenhält ein Kanzler mit
schwindendem Rückhalt in der Bevölkerung
ein geschröpfter Haushalt und ein SPD
Parteitag vor der Tür gute Gründe mit
dem Generalsekretär der SPD Kevin kühner
zu sprechen guten Abend Herr küard
schönen guten Abend die Umfragewerte des
Kanzlers sind auf einem neuen tiefswert
was folgt ihrer Ansicht nach daraus
zunächst mal verwundert mich das nicht
so sehr wenn man bedenkt dass die Partei
des Kanzlers im Moment auch keine
besonders hohen fragewerte hat und das
wiederum verwundert nicht weil wir in
tiefen Krisen sind und das meistens
nicht die größten Feiertage der
Regierungsparteien sind unser Ziel muss
sein Deutschland so durch diese Krisen
zu führen dass die Menschen am Ende der
Krisen sagen dass das gut ausgegangen
ist dass das gutes politisches
Management war ich verstehe aber dass
jetzt in dieser akuten Krisensituation
viele vor allem von Sorgen umgetrieben
sind tatsächlich könnte es ja auch sein
dass der dass der Kanzler seine führungs
Aufgabe wahrnimmt und den Menschen
tatsächlich Orientierung bietet das
scheint ihm nicht zu gelingen wie sie
sagen die SPD ist ebenfalls auf einem
neuen Tiefstwert das muss sie als
Generalsekretär ja doch sehr bedenklich
stimmen dagegen kämpfen wir an aber wir
können nicht zaubern vieles was ich eben
in dem Beitrag gehört habe respektiere
ich natürlich aber wir müssen schon mal
feststellen der Bundeskanzler ist keine
eierlegende Wollmilchsau er regiert mit
dem Mandat seiner Partei von
25,7% und wir haben zwei
Koalitionspartner und der Wunsch nach
Führung und mal auf den Tisch hauen der
erschöpft sich schlicht untergreifend ja
eben nicht da drin selbiges zu tun dann
ist ja noch nichts gelöst sondern wir
müssen Einigung finden mit zwei Partnern
die zum Teil ganz unterschiedliche
Auffassung haben Führung heißt also in
diesen krisenhaften Zeiten vor allem das
Gespräch zu suchen und die Widersprüche
in etwas gemeinsam aufzulösen und nicht
mit Getöse von sich reden zu machen wir
haben jetzt seit drei Wochen eine
Haushaltskrise wir hatten vorher zwei
Jahre in denen vor allen Dingen die
Liberalen und die Grünen aufeinander
geprallt sind ohne dass der Kanzler sich
dazwischen gestellt hätte jetzt muss
sehr dringend eine Lösung für den
Haushalt 24 her wie soll die aussehen
und wie soll er das jetzt noch schaffen
es wird genau in diesen Stunden
verhandelt miteinander jede freie Minute
wird unter den Mitgliedern der Regierung
genutzt um einen Haushaltsentwurf für
2024 nach den Maßgaben des
Verfassungsgerichtsurteils aus Karlsruhe
aufzustellen uns liegt die SPD auf dem
Tisch sie haben schon gesagt Sie wollen
die bürgergelderhöhung nicht die FDP
sagt sie will nicht an die
Schuldenbremse ran sie wird will keine
neue Notfallsituation erklären was legt
die SPD auf den Tisch die Argumente dazu
sind ja reichlich öffentlich ausgetaucht
aus unserer Sicht werden wir auch im
nächsten Jahr weiterhin eine
notlagensituation nach der Definition
der Schuldenbremse haben die FDP aber
nicht mittragen möchte genau und jetzt
können wir uns weiter öffentlich die
Argumente vortragen deswegen verweise
ich ja da drauf genau in diesen Stunden
sitzen Menschen hinter verschlossenen
Türen und tun das was man in Demokratien
bei Meinungsverschiedenheiten
miteinander macht man verhandelt
miteinander nicht im Fernsehstudio nicht
in Talkshows sondern dort wo im
vertraulichen Rahmen Lösung gefunden
werden müssen und natürlich geht der
Bundeskanzler jetzt nicht vor die Tür
und erklärt als Sozialdemokrat was sein
Standpunkt ist weil danach wären wir
alle so schlau wie vorher eine Einigung
erziähen sie dadurch ja eben nicht die
Kritik kommt ja nicht nur von außen also
sie kommt ja nicht nur von Herrn Merz
der einen denkwürdigen Auftritt im
Bundestag hatte sie kommt z.B auch vom
aktuellen ususo Vorsitzenden der hat
gesagt falls Dich in Deiner Burg in
deinem Berliner Kanzleramt noch
irgendetwas erreicht gerichtet an Olaf
Scholz falls du dich noch daran
erinnerst für welche Partei du
angetreten bist ändere deinen Kurs sie
waren ja auch mal jusu Vorsitzender kön
das Nachvollziehen eine Aussage die im
Umfeld eines jusu Bundeskongresses wo
auch Wahlen stattgefunden haben
getroffen wurde
insofern ne aber in dieser Deutlichkeit
hatte sie glaube ich schon was mit
diesem mit diesem Event zu tun aber ich
war auch bei diesem JUSO Bundeskongress
und natürlich habe ich die Stimmung dort
gemerkt dass die Delegierten uns auch
als Parteispitze auffordern wir wollen
euch kämpfen sehen das ist das was ich
dort gemerkt habete tut Olaf Scholz
irgendwie nicht hat man den Eindruck
selstverständlich wird gekämpft sonst
hätte er ja Herrn Lindner einfach
nachgegeben und hätte gesagt wir machen
so wie der bundesfinanz Minister aber er
lässt lner laufen der erzählt seit dem
Urteil dass er sich nicht an die
Schuldenbremse und nicht an
Steuererhöhung machen stimt als einziger
der an den Verhandlungen beteiligt das
hat der Lindner für sich die
Entscheidung getroffen nicht die
Verhandlung zu führen sondern
gleichzeitig auch nach außen zu
kommunizieren ob das am Ende zu seinem
Vorteil und dem seiner Partei in in
Verhandlung sein wird das werden wir
alle dann bei dem Ergebnis der
Verhandlung sehen können ich für meinen
Teil finde es richtig dass mein
Bundeskanzler der Sozialdemokrat Olaf
Scholz seiner Parteispitze die
Kommunikation an dieser Stelle überlässt
und seine Zeit lieber darauf verwendet
jetzt die Sacharbeit am Bundeshaushalt
2024 zu machen sagt der Generalsekretär
der SPD Kevin küert vielen Dank das
Gespräch